I loved fencing I took to it almost
immediately which stunt from the first
season of Wednesday left you wondering
how they did it and did you know that
Jenna Ortega did many of her own stunts
herself let's dive in I was literally in
the stunt gym every morning when I
wasn't filming for seven months number
one where did you learn how to claw like
a werewolf at werewolf boot camp of
course Emma Myers has a fairly athletic
background as it is being not only a
dancer but a figure skater and a gymnast
as well and for her role as Wednesday's
roommate Enid she had to spend every
morning that she wasn't filming training
in a stunt gym for about seven months
with one session even lasting as long as
four hours me and a couple other guys
crawling around on the floor growling at
each other it sounds to us that Emma
might have gotten a taste of how the
actor playing thing felt crawling on the
floor don't worry we'll get to that soon
that was weird I'll never forget that
number two there was plenty of flying
about on harnesses on this set most of
the area stunts were performed by
trained stunt actors like Jenny Ayumi
umhau for the scene where Rowan throws
Wednesday back into a tree Jenny was
jerked back on ropes following a count
of three two one go
a soft pad was tied around the trunk for
safety but Jenny still had to perform
this stunt multiple times and once
Callum Ross stepped out of frame Jenny
would then be dropped to the ground
number three to portray the hide stunt
performer Daniel him shoot had to act on
stalks and crutches when discussing the
difference between a stunt performer and
a stunt man Daniel said that a lot of it
really boils down to a physical theater
sort of physical acting ability and he
would know Daniel also served as stunt
double for Garrett Gates during his
fight scenes which he described as being
uncomfortable considering he was
standing under a heavy rain rig in the
Romanian winter number four would you
have guessed thing was performed by a
real actor Tim Burton insisted on
finding someone who could play the part
and so they brought in magician Victor
dorobantu who was surprisingly skilled
in contorting himself into uncomfortable
positions wearing a full VFX suit it's
pretty hard to find movements that can
express feelings Victor had to work
closely with the VFX team to make sure
that his whole body could easily be
edited out of the final product and at
one point he even had to perform
underwater number five the entire cast
had to learn how to canoe behind the
scenes videos show that it wasn't an
easy process either as the boat can be
seen capsizing don't drink the water Joy
Sunday recalls having to wake up as
early as 5 30 to train with a team of 20
stunt people she said that racing
against each other was grueling before
going on to describe how her boat sunk
in cold water on the second day of
filming stating I'm also not the best
swimmer my body just like froze up but I
was also laughing it was hysterical the
whole time number six think you could
catch frisbee like a werewolf to do this
stunt actor Maxim culo had to jump on a
trampoline to catch a frisbee mid-air
between his teeth before performing an
aerial role and landing on safety mats
provided for him during rehearsals but
but on the actual day of filming the
only thing he'd have to land on would be
the grass Maxime also served as the
stunt double for Callum Ross and behind
the scenes videos show him laughing
through everything number 7. Jenna
Ortega is a perfect fit for the daring
Wednesday Addams she's become known for
doing as many of her own stunts as
possible having once told wired I give
stunt coordinators such immense anxiety
Jenna spent roughly two months training
in fencing before filming even began and
by the end of it she'd gotten so good
that her fencing teacher apparently told
her she could have had a future in the
Olympics not to brag though I'm not
saying I'm this great fencer but I kind
of am Number Eight you might recognize
Jenny as Wednesday's stunt double this
South African dancer stuntwoman and
former Cirque du Soleil artist stepped
in for Jenna Ortega on some of her more
gravity-defying stunts and she
apparently had a great time while on set
describing herself as grateful for the
The Experience one behind the scenes
video shows Jenny scaling a drain pipe
on wires wearing a smile that looks a
little strange on Wednesday but maybe
she's only smiling because she's
performing death-defying stunts number
nine Jenna Ortega wasn't the only one
who had to learn how to fence Joy Sunday
began her training roughly one month
before filming she worked with a
Romanian instructor who she described as
being very intense at first but she said
that he really softened up especially
because I really got into it and enjoyed
it he was so passionate about it so I
took it immediately for her more
dangerous stunts stuntwoman Phaedra
sindel stepped in who Sunday has
actually worked with before she was her
stunt double on Sunday's first ever TV
job number 10. Brett Chan served as the
stunt coordinator for Wednesday he's
best known for the way that he
choreographs fight scenes explaining his
process by saying I take into play the
character's stature like how big someone
is how thin someone is and what they use
then you take their characters and their
temperament this approach makes him the
perfect person to choreograph stunts
like Wednesday's fight scene in the
diner where Wednesday uses her comment
collected temperament and smaller
stature to her benefit against bigger
aggressive bullies
the stunts on this first season have
definitely given us reason to wonder how
they'll manage to top this on the second
which feat did you find to be the most
impressive make sure to let us know down
in the comments